[موسيقى]
يتحدث عبر الهاتف الرئيس يصدر له الامر
باستلام
المال اخذت الحقيبه اليه الى مقر
اقامته في معظم الاوقات تكون حقائب سوداء
حقائب رياضيه مصنوعه من الجلد لقد سلمت
المال للرئيس في بعض الشهور يصل المال كل
يوم اصغر مبلغ 100 الف دولار
امريكي وقد يصل الى مليون دولار
امريكي حصلت وحده التحقيقات في الجزيره
على اعترافات سجلت سرا وعلى تسريب
معلوماتي
كبير ما يزيد على ع جيجا بايت من الوثائق
والصور والرسائل
تروي قصه رئيس جمهوريه المالديف
عبد الله يمين عبد
القيوم انها قصه فساد وبلطجه وشبكه دوليه
لتبييض
العمله ما الكلمات التي يمكن ان تستخدميها
لوصف الرئيس انطوائي شرس فاسد سلطوي لم
يكن يملك سوى دراجه هوائيه حينما دخل حلبه
العمل سياسي اما الان فهو ملياردير انه
زعيم المافيا هكذا يقدم نفس
وهكذا
يتصرف يقودنا كنز المعلومات الى سنغابور
ويكشف عن خطه لغسيل ما يقرب من واحد ونصف
مليار دولار عبر المصرف المركزي في جزر
المالديف مرحبا السيد ديزان كيف الحال كيف
تعرفت علي لقد رايت صوره لك لقد تقفين
اثار الرجال الذين ينقلون مليارات
الدولارات من الاموال المكدسه على
الواح كم لوحه تكديس تتوفر لديك 300 500
ليس بهذا الحجم اذا ليست كبيره طالما انهم
لا يبيعون السلاح ضميري
مرتاح اختفى احد الصحفيين الذين انتقدوا
الحكومه وضمت النيران باحدى محطات
التلفزيون كل من سولت له نفسه التعبير عن
راي مخالف تعرض للعقاب بشكل او باخر الكل
خائف
بالنسبه للعالم الخارجي تعتبر جزر
المالديف قطعه من الجنه الا ان الناس
المحليين لا يعيشون في منتجعات
مترفه
بالنسبه لهم اما ان يعيشوا في احياء
العاصمه الضيقه والمزدحمه او في الجزر
المتخلفه لم يفقدوا فردوسه فحسب بل لقد
سرقت
منهم ما يجري في المالديف امر في منتهى
البشاعه لقد تنازلنا عن عدد من الجزر لم
نبعها لقد فقد ما يزيد عن 300 مليون
دولار انا ويل جوردون لقد عشت وعملت صحفيا
في جمهوريه المالديف قبل عقد من الزمن ثم
عدت لاجراء تحقيق في سلوكيات حاكم البلاد
بعد ان حصلت على كم مذهل من المعلومات
تحتوي المعلومات على دليل مادي قطعي يثبت
صحه ما حام منذ فتره من
شكوك لم ادرك انهم كانوا يستخ الدوله
للقيام بكل اشكال الممارسات الاجراميه كنا
نسمع الناس يتندرون بذلك ولكننا اقصد حتى
الان لم نرى اي
دليل التسريب عباره عن محتويات ثلاثه
اجهزه هاتف موبايل كل شيء من الوثائق
السريه الى صور
السيلفي كلها مجتمعه تحكي معا قصه فساد
مستشري الرجل الموجود في الهاتف النقال هو
احمد اديب نائب رئيس البلاد وهو شاب في
مقتبل العمر لم يتجاوز 33 عاما نائب
الرئيس احمد اديب ومن خلال الرسائل
الموجوده في هاتفه النقال يبدو اكثر من
مجرد
سياسي انا زعيم جميع العصابات في جزر
المالديف كلها تعمل كما لو كانت اسطولا
واحدا لقد سيطرت عليها في الانتخابات
الاخيره احمد اديب الذي استبدل كره القدم
بالسياسه اصبح وزيرا للسيا في عام
2013 وزاره السياحه تعرف بالصراف الالي
لان ذلك هو ما يدر الارباح على الحكومه
كان مذهلا للغايه ما طرا عليه من تحول منذ
عام
2012 حتى العام الماضي لقد تضخم حجمه
واصبح بدينا جدا ثم بدا يهتم بالمظاهر
ويلبس الخواتم ويقص شعره بنمط معين ويضع
نظارات مع
ويقود سيارات فارهه امر لا يصدق كان يشير
الى نفسه والى اصدقائه بلفظه برو واصبح
يطلق على النظام اسم اقتصاد الاخوه كان
يتباهى بثروته وكان لديه مجموعه من الاخوه
من حوله يتواجدون كذلك داخل البرلمان لذلك
كان يسعى الى ضمان ان ينتخب الكثيرون من
اصدقائه من لاعبي الكره السابقين اعضاء في
البرلمان تكشف الرسائل المحفوظه في جهازه
كيف سطى هو وزعيمه الرئيس يمين على
الفردوس كان اديب مجرد ظل انه ظل وفي جدا
للرئيس يمين لقد استلم المال ثم احتفظ به
ثم
وزعه ما ان وصل الرجلان الى السلطه حتى
ذهبا يعرضان الجزر للبيع على سلاسل
الفنادق الدوليه كان يبيع وطننا ويسرب من
تحت اقدامنا كانت المبالغ 5 ملايين 3
ملايين مليوني دولار
امريكي
هذا المبنى يحتوي على مقر مؤسسه المالديفز
للتسويق والعلاقات العامه كانت بمثابه اله
سحب النقد وقد سحبوا الملايين بشكل غير
قانوني كان ابلو زيا قد عين مديرا لها
وكان يتلقى الرسائل بشكل دوري من نائب
الرئيس اديب لترتيب الصفقات فيما بينهما
ثلاث شيكات واحد بثلاث ملايين وواحد
بمليون وواحد بمليون هديه الاخ متضمنه في
ذلك ايضا لا تقلق يا رجل لقد منح ابلو
زياذ شريكه المتواطئ معه صلاحيات كامله
داخل مؤسسه المالديفز للتسويق والعلاقات
العامه لتوزيع الجزر وابرام كل تلك
الصفقات ولم تكن نيتهم استخدام هذه
الاموال للصالح العام بدا مخطط الاحتيال
عندما طلب من اصحاب شركات السياحه الكبيره
دفع رسم مقابل الجزيره لنقل 5 ملايين
دولار امريكي كانوا يحررون شيكا من المبلغ
لصالح مؤسسه المالديفز للتسويق والعلاقات
العامه الا ان ابلو زياد تضع توقيعه وختمه
على ظهر الشيك ثم يجري ادخاله في حساب
مختلف وتسحب قيمته نقدا
وتختل تبلغ قيمه هذين الشيكين معا ما
مجموعه 5 ملايين دولار امريكي حرر شيكان
من حساب المؤسسه الحكوميه لصالح شركات
يتحكم بها عم اديب تظهر المعلومات كيف
تزعم نائب الرئيس اديب سرقه ما يقرب من
مليون دولار من اموال
الدوله من الافضل ان يكون ذلك نقدا او
شيئا من ذلك لاننا لا نريد ان يعلم احد
بتفاصيل
صفقاتنا
حسنا تخطط الحكومه لتخصيص منطقه حره معفه
من الضرائب للمستثمرين ولقد كتب نائب
الرئيس اديب مازحا حول الفرص التي
ستمنحها
سوف نقوم بابرام صفقات خاصه بالمنطقه
الحره وليس فقط بخصوص
الجزيره
المحصنون ولكن يمكن ان تكون تكلفه التحصين
عاليه
جدا حصلنا على تسجيلات سريه لاعترافات
صادره عن رجال عملوا عن قرب مع نائب
الرئيس
وزعيمه يصفون فيها كيف استخدمت الاموال
المسروقه لشراء النفو
منذ ان جاء الى السلطه وهو يرشي اعضاء
البرلمان والقضاه والمحامين وكل شخص اخر
لقد استشر الفساد في المنظومه
باسرها رجال المال التابعون للرئيس يلوذون
فرارا في المملكه المتحده ولقد اصدرت
حكومه المالديف بحقهم مذكرات توقيف دوليه
لان لديهم الكثير مما يعرفونه عن الرئيس
يامين اظن ان رئيس خائف لهذا السبب لم يكن
يعلم ان جميع المعلومات متوفره لدي يصف كل
واحد من هؤلاء الرجال كيف كان يتنقل على
دراجه بخاريه لتسليم الرشاوى انها الاموال
التي سرقت من الشعب لتعطى لاكثر الناس
نفوذا في جمهوريه
المالديف كنت هناك وقابلت بعض كبار
الشخصيات في الحكومه لقد ذهبت شخصيا للتو
وسلمت الاموال الاموال داخله والاموال
خارجه باستمرار تاتي وتذهب
فقط اتصل بهم وهم فقط يخبرونني اين هم
فاذهب اليهم واسلم المال لم تقتصر الخطه
على استخدام المال لشراء السياسيين فحسب
بل والقضاه
ايضا من امثال علي حميد القاضي في المحكمه
العليا تفضح رسائل الهاتف النقال وتكشف
استلامه للاموال
[موسيقى]
المسروقه في الليله الماضيه سلمت علي حميد
4000 دولار
نعم حسنا
جيد في عام 2012 تم تسريب مقاطع صوتيه
ومقاطع فيديو بدا انها لرجل صوته وشكله
يشبه صوت وشكل علي حميد يضاجع ثلاث نساء
مختلفات في غرفه بفندق في كولومبو وتتضمن
التسجيلات ايضا محادثه له مع رجل اعمال
محلي قال اثنائها انا رجل يمين تثبت
الرسائل ان القاضي حميد كان يعمل لصالح
يامين مقابل اجر بما في ذلك رسوم تدريس
اثنين من اولاده في الخارج ووظائف منحت
لاخيه وابن عمه كان ذلك ثمن شراء الولاء
حتى اجراء الانتخابات
المقبله سوف نبقى جنودا الى ان تنتهي
المهمه في عام
2018 سوف لن نسمح لهم ابدا بتحطيم رئيسنا
ولا بتقويض انجازات فريقه بعد ظهور
الاشرطه الجنسيه وضع القاضي حميد رهن
التحقيق ثم بعد سته شهور تمكن نائب الرئيس
اديب من اغلاق ملف
التحقيق اقرا الاخبار لقد انقذت علي حميد
رجلا الوطني بعد سته شهور من
العمل يا اخي العزيز لقد قدمت انت وصاحب
الفخامه الرئيس اكثر مما يكفي لي ولعائلتي
وساظل ممتنا لكما يا سيدي
[موسيقى]
وبعد فضيحه الفيديو عين رئيسا لهيئه
الخدمات القضائيه انها جزر المالديف تلك
التي نتحدث
عنها نحن نتحدث عن رجل ضبط امام الكاميرا
وهو يعاشر ثلاث نساء مختلفات في بلد تتعرض
فيه الفتيات الصغيرات للجلد بشكل دوري اذا
ما مارسنا الجنس خارج اطار
الزوجيه
عندما ضمن ان القضاه في جيوبه ما علم نائب
الرئيس اديب والرئيس يمين ان بامكانهما
التصرف في مامن من المحاسبه والعقاب وقع
الهجوم على عدد من وسائل الاعلام واضرم
النيران في قناه راجي التلفزيونيه في شهر
اكتوبر من عام
2013 شاني زياد هي رئيسه القسم
الانجليزي كل شيء اح
كل شي جميع المعدات والاجهزه كانت هنا
كلها احرقت تماما ولكننا بدانا البث مره
اخرى بعد عشر ساعات من المبنى الجديد
استمررت القناه في البث ولم تخضع لمحاولات
اسكاتها وبعد عام طلب نائب الرئيس من
الشرطه تكرار الهجوم الا ان رئيس الشرطه
اقترح بدلا من ذلك تخويف مستثمري
القناه هاجموها تاره
اخرى لا اظن من الافضل التوجه نحو
الممولين حسنا زودني بقائمه
اسمائهم اختفى الصحفي احمد ريلان قبل ما
يزيد عن عامين كان يعمل مراسلا لصحيفه
مالديفس اندبندنت والتي تتراس التحرير
فيها سهين
رشيد في العاشر من اغسطس عندما لم ياتي
الى العمل ظنناه ياخذ قسطا من الراحه ثم
يوم الاثنين لم ياتي الى العمل ويوم
الثلاثاء اخبرتنا عائلته بانهم لم يتمكنوا
من الوصول اليه وحينها بدانا نشعر بالقلق
بداوا يقتفون اثار رحلته الاخيره وجدوا
تسجيلا التقطته كاميرا المراقبه له في
ميناء العبارات وخلصوا الى انه كان قيد
[موسيقى]
المراقبه استقل عباره الساعه الواحده
وحينما ترجل ريلون من العباره لم يستقل
الحافله وانما سار الى البيت مشيا على
الاقدام احيانا اتساءل لماذا اختار ان
يمشي الى البيت على اقدامه كلنا تلقينا
تهديدات بالقتل لو انه ذهب الى البيت
مبكرا لربما كان هنا اليوم
[موسيقى]
معنا هذه هي الزاويه لقد تغيرت كثيرا جدا
كان يعيش في تلك الشقه فوق هناك في الطابق
العلوي في حوالي الواحده والنصف بين
الواحده والنصف والثانيه شاهدوا رجلا وهو
يجبر على الدخول في سياره تحت تهديد
السكين وشاهدوا السياره تنطلق به بسرعه
فائقه لدرجه ان من بداخلها لم يتسنى لهم
اغلاق
الباب بعد اسبوعين من اختفاء ريوان تجمعت
لدى الشرطه بعض المعلومات اصبحت القضيه
مثار اهتمام كبير الا ان الرئيس لم يهتم
بالامر بتاتا بل واصدر اوامره الى وزير
الشؤون الداخليه بان يتريث في
التحقيق عمر لا حاجه لان تتعب نفسك في
قضيه ريل
وان حاضر سيدي
[موسيقى]
وصل في اقل تقدير يفهم من ذلك وجود تستر
من قبل الحكومه وفي اسوا الاحوال يعني ذلك
ان الرئيس ونائب الرئيس متورطان كلاهما
وانهما امرا باختطافه لقد سعينا من خلال
كل جهاز حكومي
وطرقنا كافه الابواب ولم نتلقى من هذه
الاماكن
استجابه تشك عائله ريلان بانه كان يحقق في
صفقات فساد ابرمت حول
الجزر هذا مكان استشرى الفساد
فيه فقط الناس الذين يقولون نعم دون ما
طرح اي تساؤل يجنون الفوائد من كل شيء
ونظرا لاننا لا نكف عن توجيه الاسئله
فاننا نستهدف
لم يقتصر الامر على الاختطاف وانما هناك
ايضا حقيقه ان الدوله باسرها فشلت واظن ان
هذا هو الامر الاصعب انه الادراك بانه
عندما يحصل لك شيء فان الناس الذين من
المفروض ان يكونوا مؤتمنين على سلامتك لا
يبالون
[موسيقى]
بك لقد باعت الحكومه الجزر ثمن بخس في
مختلف ارجاء المالديف واليوم لم يبقى في
جزر العاصمه ماليه بحيره واحده يمكن
الاستثمار في
تطويرها بلغني في المجمل ان ما يزيد عن 60
جزيره تم التخلي عنها لا يقتصر الامر على
الجزر بل والبحيرات الضحله المنتشره في كل
ارجاء المالديف كل شي بيع احدى اكثر
الصفقات اظما تلك الخاصه بجزيره ماو
هذا هو المكان الذي تبرم بشانه
الصفقات ماجو نفسها يمكن بيعها ب 10
ملايين دولار امريكي لو انك عرضتها عبر
عمليه عطاءات سليمه الا ان الحكومه لم
تتلقى ثمنا لها سوى مليونين ونصف المليون
الشاري هي شركه منتجعات نيو مود والتي
تعود ملكيتها الى الايطالي جندريا توسي
وطبقا لتقرير المدقق العام لجزر المالديف
خالفت صفقه القانون لانها لم تكن نتيجه
لمزاد علني ثم ظهرت وثائق مزوره لها علاقه
بالصفقه تخص هذه الوثائق شركه ترتبط بعم
نائب رئيس
الدوله في نهايه المطاف وصل المال الى
حساب تتحكم به شركه لها علاقه باحد افراد
عائله وزير السياحه هذه حاله من حالات
الفساد الكلاسيكيه حيث تمزج بين العمل
وافراد العائله
والسياسه لقد صمم المعاملات بحيث تبدو
طبيعيه ولكن في الواقع لكي يتسنى من
خلالها سرقه المال العام تظهر رسائل
الهاتف ان الصفقه تمت من خلال اشراك زعيم
عصابه مالديفي يعرف باسم تي سي ديف بدات
التفاصيل تخرج الى العلن بعد ابرام الصفقه
فما كان من اديب الا ان ساله ان كان هو من
يقف وراء
التسريب يا اخي رجالكم هم من ينشرون هذه
المعلومات لا لا اظن ذلك قله هم الين
يعرفون اننا ابرنا صفقه لكن الارقام
والتعاملات
تقرير المدقق العام ساورته شكوك بوجود
فساد وبالرغم من ذلك يعكف العمال على
انشاء 99 فيلا تحت رايه سلسله الفنادق
الايطاليه باج
اليوني تقوم الحكومه ببيع هذه الجزر
بالنيابه عن شعب المالديف ولذلك تحتاج لان
تنظر في الاساس الذي بنيت عليه هذه
الصفقات وهل حصل شعب المالديف على ما
ينبغي له ان ان يحصل عليه من خلال هذه
الصفقات جميع الشركات التي حصلت على كل
هذه الجزر لم يكن من حقها الحصول عليها
ولذلك يتوجب على حكومه المالديف استعاده
هذه
الجزر تقول شركه باج اليون الفندقيه بانها
لم تكن على علم بوجود اي فساد في صفقه
الجزر اما نيود فلقد نفت وجود اي علاقه
لها او لمالكها جان اندريا توسي بالف
خلص تقرير المدقق العام الى ان ثمه مالا
قد اختلس مما لا يقل مجموعه عن 59 صفقه من
صفقات
الجزر الاموال المتعلقه بهذه القضيه ضخمه
جدا دون ان يدرك ان الفساد قد وصل الى راس
الهرم بادر المدقق العام بتقديم تقريره
الى
الرئيس عندما قمت شخصيا بابلاغ لم يكن منه
سوى ان تجاهل الامر
تماما فقط غير الانون ثم قرروا اقاله
المدقق العام من
وظيفته وكان ذلك
انا بعد نشر هذا التقرير تلقيت انا وبعض
افراد عائلتي تهديدات
بالقتل كانت تلك تهديدات فارغه قام ضباط
الشرطه فاسدون بابلاغ نائب الرئيس اديب
بتقرير المدقق وهكذا تواط على اسكات صوت
اخر يا جماعه انتم بحاجه للتركيز على هذا
المدقق
العام لا
تقلق ربما نحتاج لان نشعل مكتبه فهو يسبب
لنا المتاعب
باستمرار تفقدنا ذلك المكان توجد الكثير
من الكاميرات في كل
مكان حسنا لكن تحتاج لان تهاجمه ايا كانت
التكلفه بالتاكيد فلنقم
بذلك
نحتاج لان نشعل
المكان يا
الهي يا الهي كانوا يحاولون اشعال مكتب
فيه 200
موظف يا الهي هذا
جنون انه ارهاب دوله تمارسه ضد شعبها
ومؤسساتها كيف لهم ان يفعلوا ذلك يا
الهول يا لق دارت هذه الحكومه لم اكن
اتصور ذلك ابدا فلنقم بذلك هذا ما صدر عن
شرطه العمليات الخاصه فلنقم بذلك اظن ان
السبب في حدوث ذلك هو انني حذرتهم من انني
سانشر التقرير فهم يحاولون منعنا من نشر
هذا التقرير في الواقع كان الامر قد دبر
في هذا المستوى ثم تورطت شرطه المالديف
التي كان من المفروض ان تقوم بمهمه
حمايتنا وخدمتنا وثبت انها تقف من وراء
هذه الاشياء شيء لا
يصدق في الجزء الثاني يستمر رئيس يامين في
ابرام الصفقات دون محاسيب او رقيب نواجه
الرجال المتورطين في نقل ما يقرب مليار
ونصف المليار دولار اتساعد الناس في غسل
اموالهم يا الهي كيف لك ان تجرؤ على قول
ذلك
مليار ونصف المليار من العمله الحقيقيه
مكدسه على الواح تمهيدا لنقلها وكانك
تشاهد احد افلام جيمس
[موسيقى]
بوند في الجزء الاول اكتشفنا كيف حول
الرئيس عبد الله يامين عبد القيوم جزر
المالديف الى دوله مافيا رجال ينقلون على
متن الدراجات الناريه حقائب مملوءه
بالاوراق النقديه لصالح الرئيس وبطانته
لقد اخترق النظام
باسره بعد قليل خطه لنقل ما يقرب من مليار
ونصف مليار دولار نقدا تكشف عن هويه
المتورطين كما يقولون المال وسخ بالنسبه
لي لا اتاجر لا بالسلاح ولا بالمخدرات
كانت جمهوريه المالديف مقرا للتفاؤل
والاصلاح انتهى عهد حكم الحزب الواحد
واصبح محمد نشيد اول رئيس للبلاد ينتخب
ديمقراطيا في 2008 ما لبث من خلال حركات
جريئه كعقد اجتماع للوزاره تحت الماء ان
طور لنفسه سمعه على المستوى العالمي
كمدافع عن
البيئه اذا لم يكن ممكنا اليوم انقاذ جزر
المالديف فلا نشعر بان ثمه فرصه كبيره
لانقاذ بقيه
العالم
[موسيقى]
الا ان مستقبل نشيد شكلته الاحداث التي
جرت في واحد من المراكز الماليه الرئيسيه
في اسيا اكتشف المسؤولون في ادارته عمليه
احتيال كبيره كانت بداياتها في سنغافوره
ونهاياتها في
المالديف كانت تلك فضيحه كبيره جدا وكميات
الاموال التي دخلت في المعاملات التي
اشتملت عليها تلك الفضيحه كانت كبيره جدا
جدا
الامر يتعلق بفرع سنغافوره لمنظمه التجاره
التابعه لدوله المالديف كان المسؤول عنها
عبد الله
يمين كان يمين هو رئيس منظمه التجاره
التابعه لدوله المالديف اسس شركه نفط
وسجلها في سنغافوره وكانت تلك الشركه تبيع
النفط
لبورما كل المؤشرات تؤكد وجود عمليه
احتيال وبناء عليه عملت شرطه المالديف مع
المسؤولين في سنغابور
للتحقيق في الموضوع بادرت حكومه نشيد برفع
قضيه في المحكمه كان يمكن ان تؤدي في
الحال الى ادانه يامين لقد حصلنا على 2في
صفحه من الوثائق القانونيه تشتمل على
تفصيل للدور الذي يقوم به الرئيس يامين
عمليه الاحتيال المزعومه تتعلق بما يقرب
من 140 مليون دولار منظمه التجاره التابعه
للدوله استوردت النفط الى المالديف يزعم
ان يامين ساعد في تحويل بعض من ذلك النفط
الى الطغمه العريه الحاكمه في مينمار جرى
تاسيس شركه سريه اخرى ثم وقع اختلاس
ارباحه كانت تلك وسيله لاختلاس المالي
بهدف الاثراء الشخصي عندما تكون مسيطرا
على كثير من اذرع الحكومه فبامكانك اساءه
استخدام هذه الاذرع وتحقيق مكاسب من اموال
الحكومه بحلول عام 2012 حصل المسؤولون في
اداره نشيد على ما يكفي من ادله لتوجيه
تهمه الى يمين بالاحتيال
وكانوا على اهبه الاستعداد للبد في
اجراءات المحاكمه ثم واقع التمرد محليا
اطيح بمحمد نشيد واخرج من مكتب
[تصفيق]
الرئاسه في نهار الانقلاب في عام 2012 كنا
على وشك الاعلان عن بعض تفاصيل تلك القضيه
كنت مهددا وتعرض للضغوط ثم اجبرت على
[تصفيق]
التنحي
ومن المؤكد تماما ان يمين هو الذي كان
يقود
الانقلاب بعيدا عن القلاقل عمدت الحكومه
الجديده الى وقف التحقيق وبسرعه اغلق ملف
القضيه وتم التحفظ على كل ما تعلق بها من
اوراق
ووثائق تمكن يمين من الافلات من المسائله
وفي العام التالي اصبح هو الرئيس
وبات هدفه الاول هو خصمه
السابق القي القبض على محمد نشيد في شهر
فبراير من عام
2015 وبعد شهر صدر بحقه حكم بالسجن ل 13
عاما قلبت الطاوله على
نشرد تفيد المعلومات المتوفره لدينا ان
الرئيس يمين هو الذي حدد بنفسه مده سجن
نشيد في شريط فيديو سجل له سرا يصف سائق
نائب الرئيس كيف تم تدبير
ذلك في يوم صدور الحكمي على نشيد استد
عودي وطلبوا مني ان اذهب
لاستلهام شيئا مكتوبا بدون مظروف فما كان
مني الا ان فتحته وكان مكتوبا فيه نص
العقوبه التي سيحكم بها على نشيد فذهبت
وسلمته لاديب فما كان منه الا ان ضحك ثم
اتصل بالرئيس والرئيس قال ان شيئا ينبغي
ان يتغير في ما هو مكتوب في الرساله وفي
تلك الليله صدر الحكم على
نشيد يبدو ان الحكم بسجنك ل 13 عاما بتهمه
الارهاب كان بامر مباشر من
الرئيس انه شيء محزن ليس فقط لانني سجنت
كل تلك المده بلا وجه حق وبشكل غير قانوني
وغير شرعي ولان عائلتي جرى اقتلاعها من
موطني فقط اضطررت الى مغادره الملضيف كل
هذه الاحكام المسيسه تجري باداره وبامر من
الرئيس يامين كنت قد اخبرت بذلك من قبل
ولكن الان ثبت ذلك لدينا بالادله التي لا
مجال للتشكيك فيها اي ان هذه الاحكام هي
بالضبط ما امر به الرئيس بنفسه لو اعتقلت
في المالديف هل احصل على محاكمه نزيهه
وعادله صفر
لماذا اذا ما بدر منك اي شيء مهما كان
صغيرا فستكون قد انت انتهيت سوف ينتهي بك
الامر الى السجن وستقع
هناك ليس هذا قضاء مستقلا على الاطلاق بل
هو قضاء مختطف من قبل السلطه التنفيذيه من
قبل الرئيس ربما كان اكثر المؤسسات فسادا
في البلاد اما وقد اصبح في السلطه وبات
خصمه في السجن تحولت جزر المالديف لساحه
لعب للرئيس يمين ونائبه اديب ما لبث ان
صعد من مستوى طموحاتهما ذهبا يعدان ل
مكيده جديده كشفت رسائل الهاتف عنها
والمراسلات
اسعى لاحضار مليار دولار امريكي لصالح
المشروع ما لبث المبلغ ان ارتفع بسرعه الى
مليار ونصف من العمله
الصعبه واحد ونصف مليار دولار من النقد
الفعلي يحتاج لان ينقل اكداس على الواح
هذه مبالغ وزنها كبير جدا كونهم ياتون بها
نقدا تعتبر هذه عمليه غسيل
هائله اشتغل نائب الرئيس اديب في المشروع
مع ثلاثه من اقرب مساع الرئيس بمن فيهم
ابن اخيه قدموا خطه استثمار في الجزر
لمجموعه من رجال الاعمال
السريين ارسلت وزاره السياحه الى الرجال
احداثيات موقع البحيره قدموا خطه
للاستثمار في منتجع مقابل مبلغ خيالي هو
مليار ونصف المليار دولار واحتال لجعل
الخطه تبدو
مشروعه الحكومه تختلق قصه للتغطيه مفادها
انها منحتنا مشروعا للتطوير والاموال تاتي
من اجل
ذلك كان الوسيط تانكو يو من سنغافور قام
بالرد على الوزراء موضحا تفاصيل
الخطه عندما تصل الاوراق النقديه الى
المالديف نحتاج الى دعم من سلطه النقد
المالديفيه لتامين نقل الاموال من الطائره
الى مقر البنك للتحقق من الكميه وعدها
وضمان ايداعها مباشره في حسابنا البنكي
كانت البضاعه المشحونه عباره عن 12 لوحا
مكدسه عليها اوراق نقديه من فئه 100 دولار
كانت الخطه هي نقلها جوا الى المالديف ثم
يرافقها الجنود الى البنك حيث يتم التحقق
منها وتعد ثم يقوم البنك المركزي في
المالديف بايداعها في حساب مصرفي خاص
حينها ستبدو الاموال نظيفه ويمكن بعد ذلك
تحويلها على
مراحل بعد ان يتم ايداع الاموال في الحساب
تحول 10 ملايين دولار امريكي منها الى
سنغافوره او الى هونغ كونج ويظل الباقي
اذا لم اجد له استخداما مناسبا بعد سته
شهور سيتم تحويل النقود الى
الخارج يتم نقل واحد ونصف مليار دولار من
العمله الصعبه جوا بحجه انها ستخصص
للتطوير ثم يجري تحويلها الى مكان اخر لم
ارى من قبل مثل هذه الكميه من النقد يجري
غسلها عبر البنك المركزي وكانك تشاهد
مقطعا من احد افلام جيمس بوند اعطى نائب
الرئيس اديب سببا واحدا ممكنا لتبرير مصدر
الاموال وقال محافظ البنك المركزي انه
يمكن فعل
ذلك كله راس مال طيار يريد الناس نقله الى
هنا وخاصه منذ الانتخابات الاندونيسيه
الكثير من اموال تجاره النفط
الخارجيه اذا كان باستطاعتهم توفير تفاصيل
مصدر الاموال ومشروعيه الحصول عليها
بامكاننا ايجاد
طريقه يبدو كما لو انهم كانوا متورطين في
هذه الصفقه المفترضه لنقل هذه الاموال
للاسف هناك الكثير من النماذج في الكثير
من البلدان لحكومات تدار فعليا من قبل
[موسيقى]
لصوص يظهر من رسائل الايميل والرسائل
النصيه ان تانكان يو كان يمثل ممولين
سريين هناك زعيم غامض يشار اليه فقط
بعباره السيد هانز ومستثمر في المناجم
والطاقه من اندونيسيا اسمه روزيه هان
يعقوب وشخص اندونيسي تلقى تعليمه في
بريطانيا يدير منجما للحديد الخام اسمه
عبد الحكم
هادي يظهر هنا في هذه الصوره مع مهندس
الصفقه الماليزي فازان حسن هو الذي انشا
شبكه من الشركات الاماميه يتم من خلالها
غسيل الاموال يظهر من صفحه فازن على
الفيسبوك انه كان في ايران في مطلع عام
2015 وهي الفتره التي وقعت اثناءها
المكيده وهذا الايميل يفيد بان الاموال
جاءت من
ايران تعقبنا السيد فازان ولحقنا به في
واحد من اسواق كولا لمبور
الفاخره سيد فازان اسمي ويل جوردن وانا من
وحده التحقيقات في شبكه الجزيره ارغب في
الحديث
ال
تف
شركتك هل تعلم شي عن ذلك ما كل هذا هل
تعرف
تانكو
كو وان كانو من سنغفوره نعم لديه شركه
ايدي لقد التقيت به سابقا عبد الحكم هادي
نعم بالطبع
ما طبيعه علاقتك به انه يتردد على مكتبنا
نعم وماذا عن روز هان يعقوب اه طبعا لقد
قابلته من قبل انه
اندونوسي لدينا دليل على نقل مئات
الملايين جوا ما يغرب من مليار ونصف مليار
دولار الى
المالديف هذا مال كثير
جدا ولتحويل الى مصرف الدوله في الهند
وايداعه في حساب باسم سيتي تراست اند
ادمنستريتور
واو هذا مبلغ كبير جدا يبدو انه غسيل
اموال لماذا لماذا احتاج لان افعل هل تسعى
لنقلها الى المالديف اتاجر منذ 35 عاما
ولم افعل شيئا من هذا هل تساعد بعض الناس
في غسيل الاموال كيف تجرؤ على قول ذلك اع
ذلك وجها لوجه كيف تجرؤ على قول
ذلك هل بامكاني احضار مبالغ كبيره من
النقد اليك وانت تقوم
بغسلها ابدا
بتاتا قطعيا لا بالتاكيد لا غير ان ذلك لم
يكن ما صرح به السيد فاديز لمراسلنا
المتخفي قبل ذلك مرحبا السيد فاديز كيف
الحال كيف تعرفت علي لقد رايت صوره
لك تنكر في شخصيه مدير تنفيذي في مجال
الاستثمار يدير اعمال عدد من العملاء
الاثرياء
جدا لقد خصصت وقتا لك هذا المساء مهمتنا
بش بشكل اساسي هي رعايه مصالح اشخاص من
كبار
الاثرياء اخبرنا بان عملائنا يبحثون عن
وسيله لنقل كميه كبيره من النقد وبان
لديهم علاقات سياسيه وهم حريصون على
السريه يفهم من الكلام وجود فساد ولما فر
من رفع الرايات الحمر اعني ان بعض هؤلاء
الاشخاص لديهم كميات طائله من المال بشكل
مشابه وبعضها نقدا وانا اعرف ان ذلك قد
يسبب مشكله لا بامكاننا القيام بذلك بدا
ان رجل الاعمال يحظى بعلاقات جيده لا
يتعلق الامر بالكيف وانما بالاشخاص نعم
بالاشخاص استعرض فازان ما الذي بامكانه ان
يفعله لنا وما ليس بامكانه ان
يفعله قدر ما يقولون ان المال قذر بالنسبه
لي انا لا اتاجر لا بالسلاح ولا بالمخدرات
هذا هو طالما انهم لا يبيعون السلاح ضميري
مرتاح ثم تحول الى موضوع غسيل الاموال كيف
تحل مشكله النقد اقصد لو كانت لدينا كميه
كبيره جدا من النقل كم لوحه تكديس تتوفر
لديك الحجم كبير جدا 300 500 ليس بهذا
الحجم اذا ليست كبيره عن جد وهذا التحويل
ضخم نعم يمكن انجازها نعم يمكن انجازها
واو حسنا بايه عمله ستكون باليورو وبالاس
هذا هو الافضل هل هذا جيد ان الدولارات
الامريكيه يمكن ان تسبب مشكله بسبب
المصارف المركزيه الامريكيه كما تع خروج
العمله وتمريرها عبر النظام الفيدرالي
يمكن ان يسبب المتاعب لكن اليورو اسهل
طبعا هذا
اسهل ما اغلقه ان الصفقه ضخمه للغايه بحيث
قد تتسبب في احداث خلل في سوق عمله
اليورو هذا بالرغم من ان سعر صرف اليورو
ليس سريعا لان السوق لا يستطيع استعاب هذا
الكم بسرعه لكن يمكن للامر ان
ينجز كانت السريه شرطا لابرام الصفقه
وتطلب ذلك اخفاء اسمائنا خلف ستار من
الشركات الوهميه دعنا نعبر عن ذلك بما يلي
لقد اغلقت بعض هذه الكيانات بما يقرب من
سبع طبقات حقا نعم
واو تحسبا من الصلاحيات القضائيه المتعدده
فهذه كميه ضخمه جدا اذا سبعه ابواب يتوجب
عليك ان تعبر من خلالها لكي تصل الى هويه
المعني وحتى هويه المالك في نهايه المطاف
فهي مؤسسه مسجله باسمي هذا لن يشير الى اي
جهه سيعودون الي ويقول نعم وفي الواقع هي
مؤسسه مسجله في بانما اه حسنا ثم من
المقرر ان تمر الاموال القذره عبر احد
المصارف سوف تاتي الى بلد في اسيا هذا كل
ما يمكن قوله نعم لقد قمت بالترتيبات مع
المصرف المركزي وكل الجهات
الاخرى لقد اخبرنا السيد فازان باننا
اسانا فهم تصريحاته واخرجنا عن سياقها
فايان حسن وتان كوان يو وعبد الحكم هادي
ورزان يعقوب كلهم نفوا ارتكاب اي انتهاكات
تتعلق بنقل اي
اموال لقد اكتشفنا كيف قام رجال يقودون
الدراجات الناريه بايصال الاموال المسروقه
حقائب من النقد تصل الى الطبقه السياسيه
الفاسده معظم من اوصلت اليهم دفعات نقديه
كانوا من كبار الشخصيات في حكومه يمن كان
احمد جزء من شركه استخدمت كواج لسارقه
اموال
الحكومه في الواقع لا نتعمل بالرسائل
النصيه فقط اتصل بهم وهم فقط يخبرونني اين
هم محمد لطيف الشهير باسم موهو ادار
الشركه
الواجهه الرئيس يامين يعرفني شخصيا لانني
كنت مشاركا كنت هناك كنت ادبر لهم بعض
امواله الاسماء الموجوده في ايصالات القبض
هذه تم طمسها بالحبر الاسود ولكن مازال
ممكنا التعرف عليها نصف مليون دولار الى
الرئيس يامين الى حسابه في بنك المالديفز
الاسلامي شيك رقم
247 موهو هو الذي اودعه في
الحساب طلب مني نائب الرئيس ايداع شيك في
حساب الرئيس مباشره في حسابه قمت بمعاملتي
اثنتين لاحظت انها كانت مستعجله وتم
تحويلها في ذك اليوم خلال ثلاث ساعات كانت
قد تحولت الى ذلك
الحساب لقد اوصلت مالا الى الرئيس حسين
محمد الشهير باسم يوته كان يعمل سائقا لدى
نائب الرئيس اديم اوصل المال الى الرئيس
على متن دراجه ناريه كميات ضخمه من المال
مكدسه في حقائب رياضيه
سوداء عاده اتصل باديب واخبره انني تسلمت
المال في بعض الاوقات يقول اذهب وسلم
الرئيس بالنسبه للرئيس الحصه ضخمه اقصد
انه كان صعبا
حملها في احدى المرات كان يمين غاضبا مني
ارسل الى اديب رساله نصيه وطلب مني تسليم
100 فظننت ان المبلغ هو 100 الف فاخذت
حزمتين في كل واحده 50 الفا نزل يمين
بنفسه فسلمت
المال نظر الي شزر وطلب مني ان اسلم
مليونا وانا سلمت 100000 فذهبت مره اخرى
الى قصر يمين وجاء الي واخذ
المال بحلول منتصف عام 2015 كدس نائب
الرئيس المال وحصل على النفوذ وكان بحوزته
ثلاث اجهزه هاتف نقال
ذهبيه كان يتنقل حول العالم وهي بحوزته
يجتمع بزعماء العالم بما فيهم رئيس
الوزراء
الصيني نصب صديقا من اصدقائه في موقع
المدعي العام بما مكنه فعليا من ان يصبح
فوق
[موسيقى]
القانون بعد ذلك تكون سلطتي قد
اكتملت كما حاول اديب الحصول على بندقيه
وعشرات
الطلقات اخي ماذا لديك الان 9 ملمتر كاتم
صوت كم
رصاصه كم
تريد
حسنا امسح كافه الرسائل من اجل سلامتنا
معا ساقوم
بذلك ما لبث نائب الرئيس ان ارتقى بعيدا
وبسرعه فائقه
في اكتوبر من عام
2015 وقع انفجار في يخت الرئيس اصيبت
السيده الاولى بجراح حمل الرئيس يمين
المسؤوليه عن ذلك
لاديب حكم على نائب الرئيس وسجن بتهمه
الارهاب لكن هل كان فعلا هو المسؤول عن
التفجير تمكنا من الحصول على هذه التقارير
الشرعيه التي لم يطلع عليها احد من قبل
بسبب انعدام الخبرات لديها دعت الحكومه
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي الامريكي للقيام
بالتحقيقات وكذلك دعت خبراء السعوديين كلا
الفريقين خلص الى عدم وجود دليل قطعي
بوجود قنبله واستنتج ان الانفجار كان بسبب
حادث وهو ما يفيد بان الرئيس استخدمه
كمبرر ليتخلص من
نائبه رايناه يمارس ذلك عمليا رايناه يطهر
حكومته لقد امر بالقاء القبض على ثلاثه من
اقرب الرجال اليه نائب الرئيس وعدد من
وزرائه اي شخص وكل شخص قد تسول له نفسه
التعبير عن راي مختلف تعرض للعقاب بشكل او
باخر ولا يستثنى من ذلك احد قبل ان يعتقل
نائب الرئيس اديب كان سلم هواتفه النقاله
الى احد حلفائه والذي قام بدوره بتهريبها
الى خارج المالديف تمكنا من خلال مصدر
الحصول على نسخه من محتوى
الهواتف لقد امكن من خلال الهواتف المهربه
والوثائق والتسجيلات المسربه الكشف عن
وجود فردوس تعرض للغزو والاحتلال
والاستلاب فشلت المنظومه باسرها فلا عا في
مثل هذا المكان الصغير حيث يعرف جميع
الناس بعضهم بعضا من اليسير افساد
المنظومه
[موسيقى]
باسرها انها اشبه ما تكون بالعصابه التي
تنشط في اعلى هرم السلطه فالرئيس يامن
متورط والشرطه متورطه والمصرف المركزي
متورط والبرلمان متورط والقضاء ايضا
متورط
[موسيقى]
لا يوجد لهذه البلاد مستقبل وبذلك لا
مستقبل لنا ايضا الكل
[موسيقى]
خائف يجري الان بيع المالديف على ايدي ه
الناس الذين يجنون المال ويثرون من جمال
هذا
[موسيقى]
البلد لقد تعرضت البلد للنهب قطعه قطعه
منذ ان وصل يامين الى السلطه ويبدو انه
سرع من وتيره بيع البلد ليسلب المال ويكد
[موسيقى]
سه كنت ساقول له ليس من حقك كالبقاء في
السلطه الان لقد فقدت الشرعيه وانت في
رايي واحد من اكثر الناس فسادا وعجزا
وسلطوية
[موسيقى]
قيول الحكومه ان المزاعم الوارده انما هي
جزء من تحقيق اشمل بداه الرئيس يمين في
فبراير
2016 وطالبت الحكومه الجزيره بتزويدها باي
دليل قد يكون ذا علاقه بهذا
التحقيق واضافت الحكومه في بيانها انه من
المخيب للامال ان الجزيره في هذه المره لم
تلتزم بالمعايير المهنيه الراقيه في العمل
الصحفي
المتوقعه من مؤسسه في مثل
مكانتها رئيس الشرطه السابق حسين وحيد
ووزير الشؤون الداخليه السابق عمر نصير
وتي سي ديف كلهم ينفون ارتكاب اي مخالفات
او القيام باي اعمال غير
مشروعه القاضي حميد وضباط الشرطه عبد الله
ديدي وسيف حسين ومحافظ سلطه النقد
المالديفيه عظيم ادم وغسان عبد القيوم لم
يستجب احد منهم للطلب الموجه اليهم بالرد
على المزب
رئيس السياحه السابق عبد الله الزياد
والكابتن احمد بابا فياض موجودون الان
داخل
السجن نائب الرئيس السابق احمد اديب
والموجود حاليا داخل السجن ينفي كافه
المزاعم الوارده ضده في هذا
الفيلم